okay Wow yeah sorry one I haven't posted
on this channel in a while and two I
just went running which is why I'm
disgusting but while I was winning I had
a thought that I forgot to mention in my
daily graces sexist video and I wanted
to mention it now before I forget about
it again because that's how my brain
works it's like one of those cages is a
bunch of bingo balls and like every now
and then a ball will come to the surface
this is who's decided that she loves
boxes oh that was a Corona box not
anymore
oh tape on my shoe okay back to what I
was saying oh okay so I have another
favorite for the month and it is a movie
called breakup at a wedding that I just
got to see last week and it was
fantastic and it was created by a lot of
my friends from the improv community in
New York and they did such a great job
with it and it's so so funny and it's
kind of exactly what the title says it
is and I wanted to recommend it to you
guys because it's available on demand
I'm not end on iTunes and it's ah I
think you're to pay to watch it but it's
really worth the price and it's cheaper
than going to the movies anyway and you
get to watch in the comfort of your own
home goose no don't take the box inside
so I just want to let you guys know that
breakup at a wedding really into it so
so funny
a lot of really great people made it so
that's it I'm
go shower I think or not life is an
oyster right